soir à l'émission que j'adore sur m6
c'est incroyable le transforma way
j'adore le principe une équipe d'experts
qui relooke des candidats condé style un
peu foireux et vous allez voir qu'il y
en a un qui va sûrement vous dire
quelque chose
le tusson on lui faire prendre
conscience que son look n'est ni
tendance ni adapté à son âge il est
parti récolter des preuves à l'extérieur
de l'agent ce qu'est ce que tu penses de
ce look théorie totalement ringard je
déteste les couleurs c'est hyper un gars
hyper louis hier
tu as vraiment pas terrible c'est pas
terrible pour avoir son personnel tout
c'est plus son âge c'est plus de son âge
et si c'était ta maman tu croises et
comme c'est ma maman a pas encore pigé
dans ce jour est content de ma mère
[Applaudissements]
ok nous touche où vous connaissez kadji
je ne connaissais pas mais tu as fait je
connaissais pas vrai quoi
oui on essaie quand même derrière sa
mêlée du mipcom déchets à côté de chez
moi rien entendu football et hommage aux
artistes ont trouvé sa compil le but de
l'om et ses plus beaux hommages
c'est dans un fascicule merci oui je
suis content de leur côté parce que
c'est des fois les mecs savage attise tu
valides et c'est bien tout cas vraiment
rené tu me feras tu me feras penser à
moi de faire intervenir sur sa qualité
[Applaudissements]
y avait deux interviews à ne pas louper
celle de maquereau ou jt ouais et celle
de jean-michel mersch et ça me dire à
quoi il a été fait à nîmes tandis que
jean mi n'ayez pas l'air tant que
chroniqueur non il est athée en tant que
docteur non dr la vraie celle d'un
mariage religieux docteur zboub de
l'hôpital de sion sera plus qu'une
consultation c'était avant tout une
interview aux médias avec des vraies
questions médias on commence tout de
suite avec valérie tv sur une
application de rencontre tu lui dirais
quoi ce serait quoi ta race darroch je
dirais je sais que tu adores les
boulettes
j'en ai deux qu'ils sont coustilles en
jeu d'attaqué pas top chef on dirait la
prochaine c'est qu'ils nous avaient
elles morini bosc évoquant les charger
dans intérêts changent dit ah oui
pourquoi franck entre nombres crapette
ok pour la crapette allez on termine
avec du glam du coquin du sexy très
section live and ici voilà dans un avion
oui à dans un avion je lui dirai voiture
est actuellement qui pilote
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aime bien la vérité ce que j'aime
chez jean michel lemaire c'est vraiment
son sens de la formule et les dieux
jeune fille quitte avec sam dire à ses
traits et des chroniqueuses de ce nom ça
oui alors je ne sais pas mais elles sont
très simples et la terre sont très très
sympa vraiment alors sabrina et marie
c'est un cas vous souvenez plus des
prénoms là ça fait dix ans que vous êtes
là vous souvenez pas du prénom des coûts
étalé un soir vous connaissez tous le
monde ici mais sans merci
c'est un benjamin très bien immobilier
canadien mais oui j'adore
[Rires]
je le vois je locale a vu tout à l'heure
et que c'est fini il acheta changement
quel la projette pas jouer très voilà un
truc louche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les mardis sur ces huit y avait le
psycho dont acer à l'onatra bravo pour
ce concert exactement concert caritatif
super initiative de ses huit super
programmation de ces 8
sauf que niveau organisation bas c'était
c8 aussi non je vais prendre la défense
de la chaîne franchement ce n'est pas
assez vite alors c'est la production qui
a un peu péché c'est pas de la faute de
ces vite ils ont fait le maximum
je vous le dis voilà et c'est une très
bonne initiative de 6 me c'est vrai que
la prod derrière à mon avis c'est un
gars qui a tout fait tout seul
mais bon on commence avec yannick noah
qui laisse la place à cannes girac
mais maintenant je laisse la place à
kenji girac
adam dunn dessous
et bien c'est pâques alger de girac
c'est package irak c'est quand il
s'appelle déjà lui en fait c'est yannick
noah et fait chanter mais tu me dis
attentes de chaque match et plus chine
bah ouais tu chantes yannick avec ton
public qui connaît tes paroles par coeur
[Musique]
est ce que ce ne serait pas le tour de
patrick bruel de bruit pour finalement
[Musique]
merci papy allez pour finir m j sauf que
même règle et affronte heures pour un
artiste et y arrive pas
[Musique]
on a le nez du maire sont des races et
huile pour cette initiative et le psycho
dont c'était très important
et bravo à yannick qui a été très bon
aussi un franchement et le coanimateur
le personnes la personne de
l'association qu'elle traitait a été
très bonne et son internat ces travaux
bravo à eux et on adore aller voilà les
dernières chef au chili une dernière à
ce que voulaient quoi du sport du
zapping qu'est ce que vous voulez
evènement le petit zapping
ok ça nous coûte que d'encaisser envie
de faire mon petit zapping samba dia
ping
oui alors c'est parti pour le zapping
dans un dîner presque parfait on a
presque appris où se situe l écosse les
gosses dont ça me fait penser à
l'amérique
puisque c'est les îles super lourd bfm
un camionneur a fait une petite demande
au président se remémorer toujours
turbine tout est jeu plus de permis
alors on fait quoi
la solution rien télématin apparemment
on n'a pas payé sa facture ds arrive on
est content de samba ou ce qui m'a plu
me resteront en gare
toujours dans un dîner presque parfait
on l'a presque appris ce qu'étaient les
crudités pas les crudités si elle est
requinqué bat là où marc crevettes selig
au tchad
[Musique]
cyril féraud s'est encore fait recaler
je ne sais pas
mais sa gueule sur france 3 samuel
etienne à des fiches sur nrj12 et mines
thomas des fiches et sur ses huit cyril
hanouna aussi à des fiches mai
[Applaudissements]